MARTY: I'm going to predict
that it is pre-1840.
NARRATOR: Marty Lagina joins
his son Alex and his friend
and business
partner Craig Tester
as they travel some
50 miles northeast
to Saint Mary's University
in the city of Halifax.
Thanks, Craig.
NARRATOR: They are
eager to find out
if the antique brooch that
was discovered on Lot 21
is, in fact, partially
made of gold.
Dr. Brosseau.
Nice to see you, Christa.
Welcome down to
the microscope lab.
Xiang.
Hi.
Nice to see you again.
Nice seeing you.
Hi, how are you?
We have something here that
I think you're going find
quite interesting, actually.
A piece of jewelry of some sort.
And I'll let--
NARRATOR: Dr. Christa Brosseau
is an associate professor
of chemistry with
expertise in the field
of electoral
chemistry, as well as
the study of metals and
their chemical compositions.
Today, she is joined by your
colleague Dr. Xiang Yang.
CHRISTA: Very nice.
MARTY: Pretty, isn't it?
CHRISTA: Yeah.
MARTY: The brooch
was found this year.
And we've had it looked at
by a gemologist already.
And it did appear that there
were places that had gold.
CHRISTA: OK.
Where did you guys find this?
MARTY: Kind of the
western end of the island.
CHRISTA: It's in
really good condition.
Have a look, and we'll
see what your machine says.
NARRATOR: Using a high-powered
scanning electron microscope,
doctors Brosseau
and Xiang will be
able to magnify the brooch
up to tens of thousands
of times its actual size.
They also will be able
to examine its chemical
composition and determine
whether it's made of gold
or any other precious metals.
Should be good.
So the dark area
here is pure copper.
That's interesting.
But the bright area?
Yeah.
Gold.
That's gold.
Well, how about that?
Gary can go do his gold dance.
He found some gold.
You've definitely struck gold.
MARTY: Yeah, I guess
I'd have to say
that's the first piece
of verified gold found
on the island.
ALEX: It's a first
for us, right?
It's a first for us, for sure.
I think this would be
considered actual treasure.
- Yeah.
- OK.
Yeah.
MARTY: Well, here's the deal.
We've found treasure
on Oak Island.
Yeah.
We did.
Woo-hoo.
MARTY: Woo-hoo, woot-woot.
And we've proven it right
here in this lab today.
Excellent.
So that's pretty cool.
It's not bad.
I mean, yeah.
That's a pretty good day.
[chuckles]
MARTY: The brooch that
was found this year
is motivating and
exciting because it's
a real piece of treasure.
You just can't deny that.
It's a piece of treasure
in the elaborate setting
found on Oak Island.
This is just the
tip of the iceberg.
There's more that
awaits us this year.
Now we need to bring
in the mother lode.
Yeah.
Thank you very
much, as always.
Xiang, a pleasure.
- Congratulations.
I'm going to think
up all kinds of things
to put in that machine.
NARRATOR: Returning to the
island later that afternoon,
Marty Lagina calls a
meeting in the war room.
He is eager to share the
exciting news with his brother
Rick and members of their team
Guys, I am freshly back
from Saint Mary's University.
Craig and Alex and I
went up there, and I--
I shouldn't be excited about
this, really, in a sense.
But I am, because--
David-- this little
gem has gold on it.
[chuckles]
MARTY: We have found our
first gold on Oak Island.
DAVE: I want more
gold than that.
Well-- come on, man.
Small victories, right?
NARRATOR: For Rick,
Marty, and their team,
the discovery of an actual
piece of golden treasure
is a momentous development in
the 223-year history of the Oak
Island treasure hunt.
It is also a major step
forward in their quest
to prove that something
of even greater value
may have been buried
here centuries ago.
MARTY: So we have this
brooch, which could be a lot
older than we ever thought.
We have the lead cross,
not mined in North America.
So these artifacts are pushing
us back farther in time
than I ever thought
we would see here.
We're finding answers.
Way back.
NARRATOR: As far as Rick,
Marty, and their partners
are concerned, as close as
they are to getting answers,
the 223-year-old
Oak Island treasure
hunt has only just begun.
So, guys, you're up to speed.
You all have all the data.
We've discussed where
this might lead.
I think we should get
back to actual work.
Let's go.